[Music]
[Music]
hello once we assumed that reason and
rationality was gradually uncover the
truth but quantum mechanics to set
theory positivism to deconstruction
philosophical realism to philosophical
relativism it seems that paradox lies at
the heart of our most revered theories
and at the cornerstones of our thought
are these paradoxes evidence that our
theories are wrong and is it essential
that they are overcome joining us to
discuss Hilary Lawson's Hillary is a
postmodern philosopher and critic of
philosophical realism he's the author of
reflexivity the postmodern predicament
and closure Sophie Allen is a lecturer
in philosophy at Keele University her
research focuses on metaphysics and the
philosophy of science and Slava Dziedzic
joining us by the miraculous paradox of
quantum physics both in his kitchen in
Ljubljana and in North London right now
he's a civilian born political
philosopher and the international
director of the Birkbeck Institute of
humanities so let's get things started
he'll you I'm gonna start with you our
paradox is evidence that our theories
are wrong and is it essential that they
are overcome or something at least amiss
with the way that we our theories
operate and I think it's essential that
we do something about it first of all
let's just be clear what we mean by
paradox it's a contradiction which
applies to the claim itself in such a
way that you cannot think the claim so
the classic example of this is the
Cretan law paradox which in its
contemporary form is probably most
easily expressed as there is no truth
now in the claim there is no truth it is
seems apparently straightforward but
it's not straightforward if you apply it
to itself because if there is no truth
does it mean there is no truth that
there is
truth are or in order to understand the
sentence do you in fact have to imagine
it to say there is a truth that there is
no truth in which case you cannot think
that idea if you look up paradox in
Wikipedia it'll tell you this is a bit
of a logical technical logical problem
and it's it's possibly been solved by
Russell's theory of types and tuskys
hierarchy of languages I don't buy
either of those things I don't think
it's a little logical problem it's found
at the heart I would argue of all of the
major philosophical systems of at least
the 20th century and for a good deal
prior to that and it comes in lots of
different forms they all have this self
referential problem right at the heart
of the puzzle so what's going on why do
we find this at the centre of our
theories and the sort of answer that I
would give is something along these
lines that we imagine or we Western
thought is in general imagine that we
are describing a world of things out
there and it's more or less accurate a
better way of understanding that would
be to think that the world is other it's
not like language at all language
divides things into things and it
divides them into characteristics but
that's no reason to think that the world
is divided into things and
characteristics it's like a metaphor for
the world but they don't enable us ever
to describe the other that's out there
there's always an infinite gap between
our ideas and the world and it is in
thinking that we might be able to close
that gap and actually say how it is that
we get into these paradoxes this account
that I've given you this story of
closure you might say well it aren't you
claiming that that's true the account
that I've given is an attempt to
describe why it's possible to describe
the world why it's possible to say
things and intervene in the world
without it having to be true it's very
tantalizing Thank You Hillary
Sophie Allen our paradox is evidence
that our theories are wrong and is it
essential that they are overcome ok I'm
sympathetic to quite a lot of what
Hilary said there but I'm going to
disagree on some things but in what I'm
gonna do philosophically here is
actually give you two views two opposing
views and one side says that okay our
theory if you think your theories are
about the world if you think your
theories are actually true if you're a
realist then it's going to be a serious
problem if paradoxes arise in your
theory because that is actually telling
you that fit paradoxes arise in the
world
that somehow if your Theory's correct if
your Theory's the right one that implies
that actually the world is somehow
contradictory now that is a very
difficult thing to understand there are
a couple of philosophers who accept that
who would actually quite persuasively
argue though we can accept the existence
of condoms that some contradictions are
true or that some paradoxes could
actually be manifested now I'm not going
to be one of those philosophers but I'm
just kind of throwing it out there so on
the one hand if you're a realist about
theories and you think that our theories
are actually about the worldview it the
appearance of paradoxes over it is
really problematic on the other hand if
you take the view and it's perhaps
similar to what Hilary's described our
theories are trying to model the world
they're trying to explain the world they
may not actually pick out what's
actually in it they may say things that
we can review they may predict and
explain what's going to happen but they
won't actually tell us what the world
contains in that case a paradox is not
quite as big a disaster when it appears
in your theory when you get a paradox
appearing you can actually look at
things and say okay we're making we're
making a definitional mistake we're
making a conceptual mistake now I think
it's not possible to eliminate paradoxes
entirely but they are going to they're
going to appear but I'm not sure it's
inevitable that they'll appear okay
wonderful and slavo Dziedzic our paradox
is over
for our theories are wrong and is it
essential that they are overcome getting
entangled in some precisely defined not
any inconsistencies East may be the only
reliable proof that we are touching the
real I think that again in his
phenomenology of spirit basically
repeats the same procedure again and
again he takes a certain let's call it
existential position and he tries to
demonstrate how if you bring this
position if you think or practices to
the end it will it will refute it sells
it gets inconsistent and I apologize in
advance for the vulgarity of this
example movie that I don't even like it
weddings and a funeral Hugh Grant
declares love two ND McDouble he did
does this in his effect that way you
know sampling self interacting
interrupting himself all the time and so
on and it's clear what's the idea
instead precisely through this inability
to declare his love in a consistent
clear statement that this very fact
somehow demonstrates that his love is
authentic a subject always in a way
fails to fully express himself or
herself successfully inability to do it
which make you a subject I don't think
we should be afraid of paradoxes but we
should definitely not confused let's
call them and I believe somehow serious
paradoxes with this cheap either
deconstructionist are gone or whatever
we're anything to say when you don't
know what to say clearly you escaping to
keep metaphoric and so on and so on so
again the alien I think that our very
distance towards reality I'm not there I
cannot grasp the world
[Applause]
[Applause]
I want us to develop our arguments just
a bit so we we may be able to work
around paradoxes and they may even drive
our progress or a sense of human
subjectivity but why are they so common
to begin with why is paradox found at
the heart of so many of our core
theories
you